there is more than 1.6 trillion dollars
of student debt and many people want to
completely forgive all that debt that is
a horrible idea and now the average
american is realizing how dumb that
would be a recent survey from cnbc shows
that 59 of americans are worried that
student loan forgiveness would actually
lead to higher inflation why
the proposals that have been put forward
they aren't actually student loan
forgiveness they would make the people
who extended the loans eat the cost
which means that those people will then
increase their future prices to recover
from the loss governments shouldn't try
to run companies and people should pay
their debts it's great to see that
majority of americans are finally
realizing this